[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's really hard to film yourself
especially trying to do desks like
putting on socks
oh my gosh how do people vlog
honestly
i have so much to learn
also
this is probably the last time you're
gonna see this bike in here until next
summer because it is too cold
i need to use that heater so it's either
going in storage or staying with a
friend
i hiked over there i think if i would
have kept hiding towards like the hp i
would have found some for sure i might
set up the telephoto because just the
way that fog is moving down through the
trees with the golden light it's so
pretty
yeah they were just like so upset
that i like slurped a little i'm like
[Music]
so
[Music]
what i like to do is i like to cut them
up a lot thinner than that
made of
[Music]
hope you feel better
thank you i will see you after sunset
bye bye
bye
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
wow
i just hiked up to the top of this peak
um it wasn't a long hike it was just
like two miles up
uh from the van but i didn't see a
single other person coming up here and
now i'm at the top and no one else is
here so
i may have actually come a little too
early because i think sunset is still
at least 45 minutes off
but i don't know if i'm gonna hang
around maybe i will
it's so beautiful up here but it's also
kind of chilly
here's my current setup
one thing
that probably seems really obvious but
that i've been just learning as i go
is learning how to vlog myself actually
shooting it's pretty tricky because
unless i carry up a separate vlogging
camera i really just have my phone
but um
yeah this is my setup up here and still
no one around it's pretty cool her hair
is looking so beautiful
my fingers are frozen
it looks warm up here but it is not it
is really cold i just heard an elk bugle
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't think you guys can see me at all
um
but hopefully you can hear me
so i just hiked down
two miles in the dark in the forest and
mountain lion country
don't recommend that
but um
it always freaks me out like i've done
it so many times and it never gets
easier
and when i start to see civilization or
cars i just get so excited
but anyway yeah heading back to the van
now
[Music]
you